what episodes are 70 episode 71 late
afternoon Chicago now flying to Tehran
tow you got your passport you're up
number one you missed that flee to
Australia yeah just back hard thinking
about work really but just broke out of
it for a second and thinking about daily
being this journey it's super
interesting I hope some of you continue
to get inspired and continue to vlog I
really wish I'd do this my whole life
it'd be so fun to make you know content
mashup content right now like these days
like really in the grind obviously I
assume that you will show some of the
fancy moments of earlier today yeah we
only go to Chicago for a few hours
I'm not giving you any content right now
d-roc I'm so livid I'm about to rip
faces well that was a nice little bright
spot in what's been a difficult morning
I'm super pissed that some executives at
vaynermedia
this is a fundamental low light for me
in the company's history I'm I have no
idea how I'm gonna build an organization
that can allow to happen what just
happened
I'm not gonna we're not gonna air out
the laundry here I will figure out
exactly how I got to this horseshit
place right now but the fact that I have
this completely setup and take ten hours
to build a relationship over the course
of two years of and have it handed to us
on a platter and to have the
embarrassment that this is is [ __ ]
asinine and is loser [ __ ] at the highest
levels dropping the ball is just not
interesting just not interesting Randi
great he's gonna see how I handle things
today versus those issues back in my
library
what about transition when I started
speaking compared to today it really
cool that I compared today's talk to one
if I was giving this talk four years ago
I would have said the following which is
and honestly if you're making enough and
you like the way you're doing it and you
love your work-life balance like do you
what's changed in my tone over the last
four years is knowing what's coming and
what's coming is a bigger tidal wave
than the one we just went through really
enjoying the journey really appreciate
the feedback from the community and also
really you know giving a lot of fun
right now being introspective right now
even in the car it would try to
challenge me and be rock that's a good
creative ideas I thought the other day
how do you talk to people will kind of
overcoming the fears of getting out on
unsocial because I think whether your
lawyer not yeah
insecurity that I I talked to them about
their first kiss driving a car going to
college getting married but like that's
what it is I don't know like I mean I
just and those are all good things I
think not adopting technology is a bad
thing meaning you can go out of business
like I don't know like mom you can lose
your clients they liked using your
lawyer somebody started a youtube or a
podcast show that they like and they go
to them and stab thanks for having me
you bet awesome thanks Beth thanks for
having great yeah no excited a huge fan
by the way
thank you you have your phone let's make
them something can its garyvee super sad
you're not here he's not gonna write can
we will meet I promise it will happen
thank you so much for the kind words and
the love brother I hope you get to meet
super soon take care alright
you're welcome
you got it right yeah I just want to
make sure
[Music]
from the front okay
[Music]
hi how are you good to see you you will
awesome come in how are you
welcome thank you of course Thank You
babies Thank You Man thank you that's
yes
[Music]
people ask dumb question I love it and I
also use it as a branding opportunity
whatever you do is that fake Sirach save
this let's put it in the background of
the show of the askgaryvee show
and I'm glad I got to talk to you
because I thought my shot this morning
saying I would do anything I could just
have a conversation for you what you can
do thank you brother thank you your
grandparents and great-grandparents
didn't have this opportunity they
couldn't do it their technology didn't
exist they didn't have the luxury the
opportunities we have and for us to sit
here and not take it and not have a
chance to get the most out of it and to
take this huge opportunity for granted
because it's new and it's hard work
feels very loser like and I'm trying to
will one or two people per talk every
day to stop doing it and so please my
friends understand how big of a deal
this is get educated on it put in the
work 50 hours of reading and listening
will put you at the top of your craft
another 50 hours of producing and
testing and getting over yourself and
not worrying and just trying will put
you in a position for so much more
success than you could even imagine I've
become realistic that that means only
three or four of you are actually going
to do this but that seems great to me
I'll take it and so I really really hope
you understood the essence of the talk
and I really appreciate you having me
here thank you so much
thank you thank you so much
okay I'll be doing Q&A thank you so much
however you take this statement I can't
control but I will tell you this this is
what it is day in and day out episode 71
it's gonna look a lot like episode 710
if we get there it's operations it's
it's people management it's putting in
the work the flights the grind its
debating the future its strategizing the
opportunity it's being practical while
on the offense
it's keeping a million different balls
in the air
it's juggling short-term goals versus
long-term ambition
and for people that watch this reddit a
man value it'll be interesting to see
like what that continuous unfiltered
reputation rep repetition of this grind
is gonna do for your viewing pleasure
there's one thing I promise I'm not
gonna pander or be concerned about the
fact that it all looks the same forever
cuz that's the punchline do you have the
tenacity and the ambition and the skills
and the hunger and the want and the need
to be able to keep doing it day in and
day out day in and day out through all
the adversities that trying to achieve
something special are naturally
structured inside
[Music]
are you like do you think you're more of
mine I think I definitely think to like
you know it's unbelievable and for all
of you at home right now I thought I was
unstoppable and great ten years ago
[Music]
yeah I mean like I'm just better and
I'll be better than like you know like
experience matters it's just part of the
equation when you're 24 and you've got
skills
you don't want to think so you're
different no it is it's like a baseball
pitcher you throw harder when you're
young but you're a better pitcher when
you're older
Toronto bound Canada baby and I think
via crappier and smarter and you know
how to allocate your time better and as
great as I'd like to think I am at
focusing on the big things I'll get
better at that I've gotten better at
that but for me you know and much like
an athlete you could be crappier at they
can't you still gotta throw the ball you
said that I put the ball in the hoop
get the puck past the goalie so you know
I don't mind getting my hands dirty
I don't mind operating I don't you know
I'll never get too fancy and sit in an
ivory tower it's just not where I come
from I just thought how wired and it's
an advantage in some ways and in other
ways I look at other people that haven't
and I'm envious then they don't have a
need or a want or desire to do that
grindy grimy [ __ ] but and that doesn't
go anywhere no matter how much money
fame opportunity yeah
[Music]
[Music]